welcome back to las vegas now it's time
for this week's pet project lori joins
us from the nspca
and she brought along someone who needs
a safe and great home i hear
that is jim bob lori this is jim bob
and he is one of five brothers they were
all black cats
that came into nevada spca he's only a
year old
and you can see what uh i'm trying to
get him to look at the camera what a
regal looking
beautiful black cat he is here again
he's only a year old
and um he's he's a wonderful companion
you know
rocky he does have just some very very
minor scarring he
apparently was getting in some cat
fights which happens a lot when you're
dealing with cats before he came to our
shelter
he is one of a lot of black cats that we
have
here is i was saying earlier it should
be halloween right now at nevada spca
because we have so many black cats
and you know there's a lot of people
that specifically call us
and ask black cats so if you're one of
them
we have a lot of choices for you now at
nevada spc and of course
you can adopt by going online and making
an appointment now
we are seeing people in our building by
appointments so that you can see the
animals in person
or you can also go see them with our
great relationship with petsmart
at arroyo crossing 215 and rainbow where
we have a number of our animals on site
monday through saturday okay thank you
so much lori he is beautiful with those
green eyes and i understand this weekend
is world cat day
or this saturday believe it or not there
is a world cup day
on saturday so if you're a cat lover and
you should buy your cat some treats
maybe a a cake to celebrate world cat
day on saturday
awesome well thank you so much lori for
joining us again if you're interested in
adopting a pet or a black cat go to nsp
nevadanspca.org or call them
at the number on your screen las vegas
now will be right